Під час пандемії коронавірусу увага суспільства виправдано прикута до найбільш вразливих груп населення -
літніх людей та груп ризику, а також медиків, які перебувають в авангарді боротьби з хворобою.
На тлі пандемії проблемам молоді приділяють найменшу увагу.
Але COVID-19 зруйнував їхні плани на майбутнє, зокрема кар'єрні.
DW запитала молодих людей у ​​Берліні, як вони справляються з викликами пандемії.
- Якщо я міркую про 2020-й, я думаю про...
- Напрочуд інакше.
- Закриті кордони. Недостатня цифровізація.
- Хто думав, що так буде? Що в цьому десятилітті, коли все настільки розвинене, пандемія може повністю паралізувати нас.
Не знаю, скільки триватиме пандемія. Не знаю, чи зможу я все ж закінчити стажування наступного року, як і планувалося.
Не знаю, чи зможу я після цього залишитися в Берліні. Це все відкриті питання. Я вважаю, що це досить складно.
Корона змінила моє життя в тому сенсі, що після закінчення середньої школи я не змогла зануритися в це берлінське життя.
Я не змогла познайомитися з багатьма людьми. Я не змогла нормально проводити час.
Найгірше було те, що я насправді хотіла поїхати до Південної Америки на рік і подорожувати разом зі своїм найкращим другом.
А потім, коли запровадили всі обмеження на поїздки, весь план просто розвалився.
Багато моїх робочих поїздок пов'язані з викладанням та виступами. Тож, відтоді як почалася пандемія, усе було скасовано. Майже все.
Я уявляла собі, як я сиджу в цих будівлях, знайомлюся з однокурсниками. Ми йдемо випити та таке інше. Тепер все відбувається виключно онлайн.
Те, що мене насправді сильно засмучує, - це те, що на моєму банківському рахунку залишилися останні кошти.
Я справді не мав грошей заплатити за наступну оренду або купити продукти.
У якийсь момент я просто працював над своїм тілом,
я залишався тут, вмикав музику, танцював і відпускав все. Я давав волю усім своїм емоціям. І всередині я запитував себе, що я можу зробити?
Для мене ізоляція стала формою розширення можливостей, я почав викладати онлайн.
Завдяки коронавірусу я усвідомила, що люди не живуть вічно і що важливі для нас люди також не живуть вічно.
І тому варто кілька разів поміркувати над тим, що говорити цим людям.
Корона змінила моє життя в позитивному сенсі. У довгостроковій перспективі, я думаю, бо я багато дізналася про себе.
Приміром, наполегливість. Не одразу казати "ні, я не буду цього робити", тому що в цей момент справи можуть піти погано.
Позитивна енергія. Можна бути в гарному настрої навіть у погані часи. Або якось змусити інших людей почуватися позитивно.
Якби зараз пандемія закінчилася, я би пішла на вечірки. Техно, рейв, хіп-хоп-вечірки.
Тоді я б справді була серед людей, серед якомога більшої кількості людей.
Я би пошукала, скільки коштуватиме найдешевший квиток до моєї батьківщини. І придбала би цей квиток.
Я хочу зробити шоу! Інтерактивне шоу, яке буде сфокусоване на дотику, зв’язку, спільності.